sophie ce que vous préférez en vous
qui
ben
je sais pas mais contradictions veut
contradiction ce que vous haïssez en vo
mais contradiction avec physiquement
non ça c'est top secret ah bon je vais
dire ce que j'aime pas en moins d'accord
mais ce que tu aimes est ce que tu
pourrais faire à ce que je préfère mon
nez tong et si vous préférez dans le
cinéma
pour tourner ce que vous détestez
l'attendre au niveau de ce fait elle
remarquer sophie marceau ce nom mais
j'aime bien les cubains je m'assois sur
les cas tu arrives à les mettre dans
l'ordre maintenant
je connais bien les la table où des
progrès depuis la boum sur la période
le film vous jouez que vous préférez
sophie en fait la vérité vérité
j'aime pas trop me voir dans les films
que j'ai faits devant moi aussi
mais c'est bien j'ai pas tout ça non
j'aime pas trop te voir
et
je ne savais pas qu'elle vous préférez
vous savez celui que vous détestez comme
dans tous les films que vous avez fait
il a bien que vous haïssez plus que tout
je pense je bizarrement alors que c'est
un homme pour lequel j'ai énormément
d'admiration
antonioni mais j'ai pas du tout aimé le
film que je fais voilà
le plus grand moment de votre vie
me réveiller chaque matin à cela c'est
bien c'est bien trouvé ça le pire moment
de votre vie à part maintenant que
le pire moment de ma vie sont deux j'en
ai ouais mais bon ce n'est pas
formidable non celle qui vous fait le
plus rire en avait plein de choses
votre jeu ne vous fait rien ouais
c'est ça que vous êtes signe c'est comme
ça que vous êtes vous dit tout non non
qu'est-ce qu'il a plus que george roy
hill a beaucoup de bien
non pas de l'argent mais s'ils n'ont pas
d'argent c'est à sec si vous fait le
plus rire à la has qui me fait le plus
rire
je sais pas je vous dirais tati jacques
tati voilà qui t'a vu encore là bas
quant à lui doublé
d'affilée dans le sillage de
ce que vous faites moi rire
je sais pas j'ai envie de dire la
justice un peu
ce que vous avez de plus sexy en vous
tous
ces noms oui tout c'est vrai enfin tous
n'ont
pas cette
chance
à
c'est que vous avez le moins sexy
saladier s'appelle non plus
ce que vous regardez en premier chez un
homme
à ses yeux
[Musique]
c'est là qu'on regarde non et on dernier
son dos parce qu'il sent pas
commis par le vient
ce que vous regardez en premier chez une
fille
pas ses yeux aussi moi je regarde les
gens résume je vous regarde et en
dernier chez une fille sans doute
atteint souvent
à
la question vous préférez quoi dans
l'amour le sexe à le sexe est dans le
sexe sexe sais que vous détestez
allait changer la morgue les menaces
éclats la vitre de la boum a changé
parce que vous détestez dans l'amour
quand ils servent à attaquer sans la
voilà et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de 1h10 tube abonnez vous il mettait un
peu de bleu